Chris do you have your passport is it
with you I do have my passport it is
locked up safely I check on it every
three to four hours because I will be
getting out of here what I need to get
out here yeah i'm the same way you leave
it in the hotel safe you lock it up and
then you check it every five minutes it
never eaten hours uh no question all
right we'll get to the basket ball on a
second what what are you why me what's
the word down there this morning I
assume this is the only thing people are
talking about right the Lochte story
yeah it's incredulous uh I would say is
how I describe people down here because
initially you know after the when the
story first broke it was oh man that
happened to be us swimmers but we've
been reading reports of that happening
to people down here for 10 days now it's
been no members of the Australian
delegation you know European nations
have been you know mugged so this was
just another few people you could add to
the list so it was a story for you know
12 hours but everyone started to kind of
move on until all this stuff start to
evolve and like you were just saying
it's it's hard to it's hard to kind of
imagine the motivations of a Ryan Lochte
to could potentially have made some of
the stuff up or all of the stuff up I
mean this is a grown man 32 years old
who may have just you know fabricated
something that that I still can't wrap
my head around why he would fabricate it
so everyone is still kind of you know
curious for answers and I don't think we
really got the ante answers after
listening to what Matt Lauer said last
night on NBC right which is he had
spoken to lock down the phone and some
of the details seemingly especially with
the placement of the gun near the head
most notably were slightly different
that doesn't mean it didn't have any
kind of how you like tell your you
embellish a story for your buddies not
for public consumption with that it just
it's it's it's head scratching and now
looking at this is what what lock is
known for I mean this is this is the new
story not what he did in the pool
is the new story this is going to be one
way or the other hanging around his neck
you know way more than the medals do
yeah unless they actually find the
alleged perpetrators and this whole
thing goes away but I have a sneaking
suspicion that even if this story is one
hundred percent true you're never going
to find the guys that allegedly robbed
them that is no shot no no the only hope
they have is that if this did happen
that they do find the cab drive but even
when the story first broke i didn't i
didn't think they going to find the cab
driver either there there hundreds if
not thousands of cab drivers here in Rio
and I don't know if any of them are
eager to go talk to the police about
something like this so I you know I
don't think we'll ever get any clear
resolution frankly know if you're the
cab driver too and at this point it's
turned into a 8 a thing of national
pride to paint Ryan Lochte and the other
Americans as Liars here why would you
come forward and ruin the good story but
again that's that's assuming that it did
happen in assuming that anyone has any
other as anything other than good
intentions anyway Chris Mannix from
Yahoo's the vertical down there covering
both basketball and boxing the game
yesterday the basketball game in which
they whooped up on Spain 105 278 it was
there a sense of relief that maybe they
finally stopped sleepwalking here uh you
know I'm sure on some level there was
but I don't think there should be any
sense of relief I mean they clobbered
Argentina in the exhibition schedule
they did it again last night argentina
just is tailor-made right now for this
US team they're older they lack superior
athleticism at this point they don't run
a very complicated offensive system and
they didn't you well from the outside in
addition they don't have any signs to
match it up with the US team so now that
that was you know in some ways expected
what they did last night what's going to
be challenging is how do they handle a
Spain team that runs a lot of motion
offense that runs their shooters like
meritage and Rudy Fernandez off-screen
that has an elite big man in Pau Gasol
that they can throw the ball into the
post to I mean that it's going to be an
entirely different challenge
for the US team faced explained a lot
more and that's going to be a semi-final
again it's Team USA we're talking
basketball here with Chris Mannix
against spain spain whooped up on france
92 267 the comments a couple of days ago
I think from Paul George Chris correct
me if I'm wrong that we thought it would
be easier how are those taken well I
mean look babe I'm sure internally and
especially for a lot of these guys ten
of these guys who are playing in their
first Olympics they did expect it i mean
look dating they cruised in the
exhibition schedule but beating up on
China and Venezuela and in Argentina is
just not the same as facing teams like
Australian Spain that have been sending
elites i Donna Lee but certainly decent
to above average NBA players to the
Olympics year after year and I don't
think they were prepared for this type
of stuff the big thing and the big
challenge is defensively I mean look
they they have maybe the best defensive
mind in the NBA in Tom Thibodeau on the
bench they've got four guys who are on
either the first or second all-nba
defensive team and yet they're
struggling and the reason they're
struggling is that defensive continuity
is not something you can learn in a week
or a month it's the kind of thing that
takes time and the reason they're having
trouble with these sophisticated
offenses is because they don't trust
each other yet because they haven't
played enough together to understand
where each guys going to be and how that
defense can can gel and I don't think
that's going to change i think spain is
going to present a lot of problems I
think if it's Australia they're going to
present a lot of problems in the gold
medal game this this defensive problem
is woman's going to keep cropping up and
USA basketball is going to have to
school or 95 100 points in these next
two games I think to win or with day
hime there they could just go to three
there you know that that's a thought and
certainly one that that I wonder it Mike
chef you would would ultimately explore
but again if something these guys aren't
used to doing right and you know you saw
last night when teams are trying to go
at them 101 they can't do it USA
basketball is great and on the ball
defense the problem becomes when teams
not moving the ball around the perimeter
and screening and running these complex
systems they just don't know how to
match up with it Chris Mannix from the
vertical with basketball
boxing as well down there the IBA Chris
the International Boxing Association has
sent home a couple of referees and
judges after a review found quote less
than a handful of the decisions were not
at the level expected you at an irish
boxer screaming foul and actually
dropping some four letter word saying
they're cheats almost suggesting that
you know paid off by the russians and
again this is him screamin and yellin
gary russell lost that split decision as
well he's an American to the fighter
from Uzbekistan Floyd Mayweather you
take you know consider the source there
said the Russell was clearly robbed
what's going on yeah it's the same story
different year with would be nice keep a
negotiation they've got this happening
all the time I mean you go back to
nineteen eighty eight when Roy Jones
once was robbed you know awfully in the
gold medal fight back then every single
Olympic cycle you have these these
events the problem is and you know there
are many problems obviously but the big
problem is the bottom line is they don't
have an appeals process and there should
be an appeals process if you see a score
that is so egregiously poorly scored
that that is so awful you should have
the ability a team should have the
ability to appeal that and there should
be an independent panel that goes back
and watches the fight and if they think
it's clear that that decision was wrong
they should overturn it they have not
had that i'm pretty sure in the history
of olympic boxman a referee's appeal for
years ago but they did away with that
too so the one thing they disel imp
o'clock singh you know governing body
has to do going forward is to change
that rule and create an appeals process
because this some of the stuff is a joke
I mean Gary Russell the American he won
that fight Michael Conlon the Irish guy
he won that fight there was a gold medal
fight between a Russian that uh and I
believe he used Becca Stan fighter I'm
not entirely sure there but the Russian
won the fight he should not have won the
fight they should be able to appeal and
get this thing right because it's it
should not be this difficult enter to
store a three-round fight it you
shouldn't you should be confident enough
especially when these judges I'll
consider the best of the best there a
pool of 300 judges 36 from around the
world or chosen the best judge in the
world should be getting these fights
right but it keeps
happening and we don't hear it for
gymnastics although people can argue
about scores why does it keep happening
Chris for boxing I I don't know and you
know obviously there's there's a width
of shadiness the shirt and wonder about
and say what's going on behind the
scenes you know I asked and I I be a
official about that last night he was
vehement that there was no evidence
anything like that they just decided to
send these judges home because they
didn't feel they did their job right but
you know year after year you know it's
it's something that has to be addressed
but I think the only way to properly do
it though is the appeal if you have the
appeal in place even if there is a bad
decision you can go back look at it and
get it right all right you're safe
though you're cool you're good you okay
and real i'm good i'm looking forward to
friday night to what I believe will be a
monster performance by Ricky Rubio and
the Spanish national team are you
calling a Spanish win right now is there
you know no I'm calling a Spanish loss
but Rubio with 20 and 10 in defeat I
think first of all Spanish stacks I mean
they're a team yes that was true in 2008
and it's true now oh chris maddox for
the vertical and Yahoo as dad calls it
yahoo in rio be safe please Chris you
got hander all right talk to you later
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience